we have a voicemail number which is 2192
david p
at the top of the show today we covered
the dan crenshaw interview with joe
rogan
i got tons of messages and and
voicemails about it
here's one that's asking about sort of
like what's going on with dan crenshaw
take a listen
hey david did you happen to catch dan
crenshaw on joe rogan
last week is he just stupid or is he
just pulling this
to uh continue the tired conservative
logic on how
taxes and society should work i
i think he's just as dumb as madison
cothorn and
lauren bobert and the like where all the
intellectual conservatives in the
government
so my i addressed this a little bit in
the first segment
i think that dan crenshaw knows he's
bs'ing
i don't from everything i know about dan
crenshaw uh
he's smart enough and informed enough to
know
that the things he said to joe rogan a
couple of days ago
and the things he said on fox news last
night about what is fascism and
medicaid and you know immigration i
think he knows that it's bs
but he bel he correctly believes the
average trumpist will believe it
if your position is that no dan crenshaw
really is ignorant
uh let me know but my best assessment
right now
and it can be difficult to tell
sometimes is that crenshaw
is gaslighting not crenshaw is stupid
we have a bonus show today on which we
will be discussing
the push for a fourth
coronavirus stimulus check there is a
push for this we will talk about it
we will also talk about a utah law that
requires
biological fathers to pay half of
pregnancy-related medical costs
period regardless of anything else and
lastly jeff bezos has come out in
support of a higher corporate tax rate
which joe biden is now pushing
my question is if you deduct
your taxable income down to zero does it
matter what the corporate tax rate is in
other words
if amazon is paying 21 of zero
or 28 of zero or 35 percent of zero why
the hell does amazon care what the
corporate tax rate is i think that
there's a
propagandistic element to this which we
will talk about on today's bonus show
get instant access to the bonus show
simply by signing up
at joinpakman.com i'll see you then